[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour ce
deuxième numéro du 7 8 dossiers une
émission pour décrypter une thématique à
travers une série de reportages et pour
ce mois de novembre nous ouvrons le
dossier du marché de l'après vie selon
les chiffres de l'insee plus de 9000
personnes sont décédées en 2016 dans les
yvelines soit une augmentation de 7 5%
depuis 2014
même tendance au niveau national une
opportunité pour les acteurs du marché
de l'après vie au sommaire pompes
funèbres et fleuristes
combien coûte une cérémonie la réponse
dans cette édition nous nous sommes
aussi penchée sur la gestion d'un
cimetière par une mairie puis vous
visiterez une structure insolite
spécialisée dans la crémation des
animaux mais pour commencer je vous
propose de découvrir les
caractéristiques de l'assurance décès de
l'assurance vie reportage
[Musique]
protéger ses proches financièrement
après sa disparition c'est possible
notamment avec l'assurance décès prenons
l'exemple d'un assuré qui souscrit un
contrat d'une garantie de 100 mille
euros pour dix ans ils paient une prime
mensuelle et en contrepartie l'assureur
est en charge de la gestion du dossier
en cas de décès avant la clôture du
contrat les cent mille euros sont versés
aux héritiers disons que pour une
personne qui a 40 ans qui veut se
garantir pour cent mille euros
on a une somme dans des primes qui sont
relativement modestes en est à 30,35
euros par mois après si on veut un
million d'euros et si on a 50 ans on
peut tout de suite monté à des 100 ou
150 euros par mois
les inconvénients c'est que c'est à
fonds perdus donc il faut vraiment que
le décès se fasse durant la durée du
contrat
l' avantage c'est que ça permet de
donner aux héritiers une somme pour
continuer à vivre et ne pas réduire leur
train de vie
autre produit financier transmis en cas
de décès l'assurance vie le principe
épargner un capital avec deux
possibilités pour l'assurer première
solution un investissement dans un fonds
sécurisés principalement composée de
dette française la rentabilité dépend
alors de l'évolution des taux d'intérêts
deuxième possibilité il peut choisir des
fonds profilés avec un mélange de titres
financiers de type actions ou
obligations avec un niveau de bénéfice
un certain en fonction du marché ce qui
est un petit peu dommage c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les taux des fonds en
euros ont beaucoup baissé puisque on
donne à peu près 2 % de rendement et
qu'on essaye donc pour un petit peu
relancé ce rendement de mélanger les
fonds en euros avec des fonds en unités
de compte et des fonds profilés hervé
rocheteau dirige le service succession
d'une banque basée à montigny le
bretonneux
il intervient après le décès des
personnes assurées différentes
vérifications l'acte de décès les
documents notariaux l'identité des
héritiers et parfois des certificats
médicaux son rôle accompagner les
proches du défunt
alors elle est décédée le 25 août les
sommes en jeu sont supérieurs à 150
mille euros en ce qui concerne l'
ensemble de l' épargne et pour les
presser un peu moins de 50000 euros
le prêt était assurée justement par le
biais des nations ce décès ce qui
permettra le temps de les libérer de ce
prêt et ils vont pouvoir conserver toute
l'épargné
c'était l'intérêt de l'assurance décès
dans ce cas là il y a de l'assurance vie
avec plusieurs contrats des contrats
avec des clauses standard c'est à dire
personne de nous mais et des contrats
sur lesquels au contraire il y à des
enfants ou des petits enfants qui sont
nommés qui vont pouvoir être réglé très
rapidement
généralement sous un mois donc on fait
vraiment haut au plus vite
lors des neuf premiers mois de 2010 est
les sociétés d'assurances ont collecté
80 17,3 milliards d'euros de cotisations
mensuelles pour l'assurance vie
ce type de produit reste le placement
préféré des français 43% d'entre eux
choisissent cette épargne selon un
sondage au doxa linxea devant le livret
a ou le pel
le marché de l'après vie représentant
françois 870 millions d'euros dans les
yvelines cette entreprise de pompes
funèbres implantée à magny les hameaux
en terre chaque année entre 200 et 230
personnes pour répondre à cette demande
la structure propose un service tout
inclus avec notamment transport de corps
maison funéraire organisation des
obsèques des prestations qui ont un coût
lorsque nous additionnons un petit peu
tous toutes ses prestations
eh bien on peut on peut très facilement
se retrouver entre 4000 euros et cinq
six sept huit mille euros s'il ya besoin
de la fabrication d'un caveau par
exemple on peut toujours avoir un prix
moins cher
bien évidemment mais tout dépend de la
prestation que l'on offre en face
l'entreprise propose dans ses murs des
stèles des cercueils pour un coût
compris entre 600 et 2600 euros et des
urnes pour la crémation
après ces cercueils de crémation donc
nous pouvons mettre nous pouvons
utiliser ces urnes et nous avons ici
plusieurs modèles d'urnes il y a des
urnes biodégradables des urnes en résine
des urnes en métal des urnes en bois
aussi voilà nous commençons à 45 euros
puis ensuite on peut retrouver des urnes
à 200 250 euros pour les yeux on en boit
autre marche est impacté par les
enterrements celui des fleurs chez ce
fleuriste installée à monti le
bretonneux on réalise entre 5 et 6
préparation floral par mois pour des
obsèques 5 à 10% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel
la semaine dernière j'en ai eu à 150
euros ça va entre 150 206 et un comité
d'entreprise qui prend pour un employé
ça peut aller jusqu'à 250 300 euros 1
on essaye de faire au mieux pour garnir
le plus possible pour que les gens et
quand même pour leur argent
un prix conséquent qui s'explique par le
temps passé sur chaque préparation par
les fleuristes professionnels passent
entre dix et trente minutes pour choisir
les fleurs et pour les assembler
plusieurs minutes sont également
nécessaires pour créer le ruban qui sera
installé sur les gerbes
donc on a emmené à où il ya déjà des
mots mais tout n'est
on n'a pas tous les maux quoi donc on
est obligé de prendre certaines aides
voyez cda et créer notre propre ruban
quoi ce qui est ce qui nous prend un peu
plus de temps tout dépend ce qu'on
marque si c'est quelque chose de course
ça va c'est quelque chose sincères
condoléances si on n'a pas de coupure un
client qui rendent pour des fleurs ou
autres faut bien compter dix minutes
pour faire un ruban
chaque année en france plus de 600 mille
décès sont enregistrés un marché qui ne
devrait pas mourir dès demain
[Musique]
la nature reprend vie autour des 12
minutes sépultures du cimetière des
gones arts de versailles
depuis 2009 la ville n'utilise plus de
pesticides dans ces quatre cimetières
ça implique non plus de chercher à
supprimer l'armée a de la réintroduire
donc on a fait énormément de ré
engazonnement d'aller de trottoirs même
on a supprimé toutes les aides qui nous
prenait du temps tu avoir une réflexion
globale quand on travaille sur le zéro
pesticide c'est pas chercher à supprimer
l'armée à la réintroduire réintroduire
le plus possible de végétal payet
systématiquement avec du broyat de bois
tous les arbustes les massifs fleuris
les les pieds d'arbres également 18
hectares d'espacés verts sont
aujourd'hui labellisé eco jardin du
gazon et planter des zones sont
revégétaliser là où le béton étaient
installés il ya vait anciennement des
travaux qui avaient été placés et donc
comme il y avait plus personne
du coup on a gardé cette cette partie
cette parcelle là pour pouvoir mettre
des vivaces dans ses partenaires avant
le zéro phyto 130 mille litres de
produits mélangés été répondu dans les
cimetières versailles est un pack a
aussi dû franchir la commune de saint
cyr l'école avec la loi la baie les
produits phytosanitaires sont interdits
depuis le 1er janvier 2017 dans l'ancien
cimetière 46000 euros ont été investis
dans des travaux un décapage complet
enlever la terre sur plusieurs
centimètres de profondeur pour enlever
les racines ensuite on a rapporté là
dessus de la terre végétale et on a
planté un gazon spéciale à pousse très
lente quand il sera terminé
ça sera une pousse très près serré qui
empêcheront les mauvaises herbes de
pousser un cimetière géré par un agent
des services techniques
c'est le plus grand des deux lieux de
sépulture de la commune avec près de
1000 concessions quand vous regardez la
taille des cimetières a lâché à la main
une par une
c'était pas possible de le faire donc le
fait d'en gazonné ici toutes les années
ça permettra de ne plus avoir ce
problème
l'autre cimetière serait un peu
différent parce qu'il est entièrement
vers lui et il a été créé pour ça dès le
début malgré une place prépondérante de
la crémation les cimetières gardent leur
importance selon un sondage 2015 des
services funéraires de paris
49% des français préfèrent les
inhumations
offrir un service funéraire à son animal
dans la dignité et le respect c'est
l'objectif de cet établissement installé
à guyancourt le crématorium pour animaux
accompagne chaque jour des familles dans
la perte de leur compagnon il propose un
service de crémation collectives mais
aussi individuelles au même titre que
pour un humain on va préparer l'animal
on va l'installer dans un petit cercueil
et on va procéder à un recueillement
c'est à dire qu'on va présenter l'animal
aux personnes vont avoir un petit temps
qui leur est propre pour dire au revoir
à leurs compagnons éventuellement
laisser un petit jouet un petit mot si
les personnes ne souhaitent elles
peuvent rester présentes dans la pièce
pour ses dires à l'introduction en ces
moments où on va déposer le cercueil
dans l'appareil de création quand les
personnes décident d'accompagner leur
animal c'est un choix mûrement réfléchi
ça peut être comparée à un geste d'amour
parmi les 6000 à 7000 animaux traités
ici chaque année plus de la moitié sont
en crémation individuelle
un geste d'amour encore peu popularisé
seulement deux structures de ce type
existent en ile-de-france et les
propriétaires se déplace de tout le
territoire
on a des personnes qui viennent du
centre des personnes qui viennent de
l'as des personnes qui viennent du nord
sont des clients réguliers qui viennent
damien des clients de dijon malgré
qu'ils aient d'autres circuits j'irai
classique à leur portée voilà il préfère
vraiment et par habitude
et par respect et par amour venir ici
pour une crémation individuelle
classique comptait 237 euros pour un
chien ou un chat
créé en 1995 le site a été repris en
2015 par le siav service d'inhumation
des animaux familiers
l'offre est désormais plus personnalisé
et l'établissement a été modernisé
crémation est actuellement en cours sur
cet appareil on va avoir dans
différentes informations concernant
battu par la traçabilité donc le nom de
l'animal le numéro de la crémation
et puis des informations techniques
notamment les températures et bien de la
chambre principale et de la chambre
secondaire là on voit que
la chambre principale est à 800 30
degrés ce qui est on va dire la
température requise pour la crémation
fabrice a rejoint l'entreprise en 2014
après avoir travaillé dans les pompes
funèbres
ils sont cinq à accompagner les familles
quatre humains et en chat patch est ici
depuis deux ans son rôle est essentiel
patch est un collègue
voilà qui sert à la crise et mis qui va
accueillir les personnes qui se
présentent ici il va les accompagner
durant la crémation à leur apporter un
petit moment de réconfort et
éventuellement de rechange et des idées
c'est devenu un compagnon indispensable
pour nous un compagnon pour adoucir la
tristesse que procure la perte de son
animal en france plus d'un foyer sur
deux possède un animal de compagnie
c'est la fin de ce sept huit dossiers
merci de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
le site internet ou sur l'application
mobile télé 78 à bientôt pour décrypter
un nouveau dossier
[Musique]